musique le retour de Santana un papi du
rock comme on dit l'une des stars des
années 70 depuis quelques années son
mélange de rock et de rythme latin gag
des adeptes Olivier l
grgory
deireilding un autre monument monte sur
[Musique]
scène le se vrai me la fierté des latin
l'antrana
[Musique]
36 ans après ses débuts le Mexicain
Carlos disyle toujours le son
[Musique]
Santana c'est une relation étrange je ne
connais rien de ma guitare j'apprends
toujours qu'est-ce qu'elle fait je veux
pas être mare
so quand vous connaissez tout vous
n'avez plus rien à faire sur cette terre
alors allez sur une autre planète et
apprenez à
[Musique]
nouveau h est il'en dans des paradis
artificiel la drogue Conn 20 anné d'éche
de purgatoire dem sa
[Musique]
musique
mon c'est l' de
servir restand service bon la nourriture
est
meilleureour la
les j'espère vous avez fa nous avons la
bonne
nouriture reprend la recette qui a fait
son succès un bon vieux ép de rythm
latin et
africain Carl Santana croit en Dieu lui
dont la résurrection est une sorte de
miracle